es un pájaro o un avión no es nato polo
con una concentración brutal y un
equilibrio alucinante el acróbata
francés bajó el martes su récord mundial
de cuerda floja y recorrió 2200 metros
de longitud subido en una cuerda floja
conectada a la avería del musa michel
edu que ahora estoy realmente eufórico
estoy súper feliz es curioso porque a
veces ha sido mucho más difícil de lo
que imaginaba y a veces ha sido fácil es
una experiencia muy intensa docencia mis
pagos de datos atado a un arnés ya una
cuerda de seguridad el temerario
equilibrista tardó dos horas en
completar su travesía pero hubo un
contratiempo polán pareció perder el
equilibrio a pocos metros de la meta su
equipo dice que se cayó por razones de
seguridad aunque la caída parecía todo
menos segura a pesar de la caída por la
pulverizó su anterior récord de mil 662
metros de recorrido a una altura de 300
metros en 2017 por la está acostumbrado
a realizar cruces
espectacular en el pasado se ha
enfrentado a la torre eiffel el pan de
azúcar del río y el mundo